un héros est maintenant très
loin le temps des listes jardin
mais sans plus elle sera
opposée à une cuisine que nos
cosmétiques et ça la femme le
quitte a bien compris
installé à trouver la fontaine
depuis 25 ans l'entreprise
familiale jean claude von essen
1 l'homme
rien n'a changé dans les champs
depuis plus de mille ans il faut
toujours choisir des fleurs ni
trop fermé ni trop mature d'un
geste sec en arracher les
détails sur tout
le faire rapidement
sans plaisir puisque l'on vient
pour le matin déjà ancrée bon
ça sent bon parce que les
échos
certains se présentent pour le
matin ses connaissances en
matière de la flore sont très
volatiles il faut absolument
qu'on était en plein soleil se
lève
ce sens en fait c'est une
mercerie
où les rosiers fleurissants
pour la première fois
en privé les fleurs si vous
l'achetez jeunes plantes et
favoriser ainsi leur croissance
quand il ya plein de temps
claude métivier a proposé au
gosier risque est doué de les
débarrasser de ces roses un peu
trop gourmande ceux-ci ont tout
de suite accepté
claude métivier ancien
professeur de biologie de chimie
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de
valoriser ses pétales matières
premières de l'eau de rose
à l'origine sa petite
entreprise était installée
dans un petite troupe l'eau qui
l'habite entièrement aménagé
avec ses enfants
il faut remonter en 93 quand on
a descendu dans l'en-but ici
parce qu'on a déjà entamée
lundi
c'est un alambic ligne à
mais effectivement c'est il y
avait une certaine complicité
entre nous c'est normal sans cet
outil je ne pouvais pas faire la
précieuse au procès
problème c'est que quand on
s'occupe d'une mais à un moment
je ne savais pas
il faut que le feu quand il faut
il faut que ce soit le plus in
her possible ça veut dire qu'il
faut en permanence être là
pour eux pour gérer les choses
étant maintenant il faut
cl
il ya un autre fameuse
normand
il faut respecter aujourd'hui on
ne l'abandonné
l'inertie
a donc remplacé le cuivre
l'électricité le bois ils
exigent les analyses
l'acquisition du distillateur
chaque été ce sont près de 10
tonnes de pétales qui finit
dans cette cuve
on dessine entre 100 et 300
pilotes de talent
alors qu'au niveau de la
récupération on récupère 40%
du poids les pédales en
gonflant leur propose
on peut si on va mettre 100
kilos après 48 jours
il faut voir la balle roule
désormais
ce transport
environ une heure trente plus
tard
l'eau de rose c
après analyse
il n'y a plus qu'à l'embêter